the year was 1996 it was a different era
for memes before viral videos before
anybody argued over whether it's a gift
for a jiff its gift jeff has peanut
butter there was the dancing baby
[Music]
what is the dancing baby
who better to ask than his father
Michael Gerard what are you doing here
the dancing baby remember when the
dancing baby while Robert Murray and I
work together to design the animation
the idea was to show that movement could
be programmed and projected onto
different characters so Autodesk the
company that Michael worked for started
sitting around the software to other
developers and animators it was just
another demo film until it landed on the
LucasArts server it was there that ROM
Lussier tweaked the original file
converted it into a chip and thenthen
email would change his life forever so
we thought we should ask what about his
experience but you know every time that
you've got male voice rang welcome
you've got mail
files done goodbye it was another
goddamn dancing baby even I got an email
that goddamn dancing baby that point on
it was unstoppable everywhere you looked
there was a dancing baby on television
on t-shirts on ties and commercials even
boxers boxers yes Michael boxers
there's all begs the question what is it
about the dancing baby that makes it so
irresistible what does it say about us
have you heard of the uncanny valley
it's a paradox where the more a
computer-generated figure resembles a
human the more will you become
revolted by it the dancing baby is the
uncanny valley
the dancing baby is the uncanny valley
it's been over two decades since Gerard
and his team unleashed their monstrosity
of the world does he regret it
yes 100%
[Music]
well better given here for joining CMI
achievement but coming soon some united
sir I think you guys know really fast
enough I can even hear him again
[Music]
here in the st. petersburg apartment
building you can find tatiana subha tina
better known as the green-screen grandma
a retired engineer Tatiana has attracted
a following creating some unique content
for YouTube
Tatiana's channel has almost 30,000
subscribers and over two and a half
million views pop idealist buy
chocolates illegally linear the canoes
Mikasa prism surprising because Tatiana
is completely self-taught la Monte young
vigil event led SPG's aquella mujer que
da vigil a pole in a bikini ponds Muslim
dollies in starett Buddhist art for
master guru Sri soon appears programa
premier Pro Skater a co-producer montage
what I became of resin here which allah
prophet muhammad o publicity once she
graduated from puppetry a giannis
channel really took off there was one
video in particular that really
propelled her to the national stage na
minha hidden a man into available in
limine young prostitutes poem tota via
sheer moto truly Kotori yes nila the air
would you want a mobile article by a
bicyclist or a smoker
he took a role on the Chinese nation the
so beautiful the risk level quite a
scaling just ask you a think aloud what
a communion with the frania rhythm it's
very large and growing audience the
general appearance of a star yes I stole
her honest attack minion Roberto
youtuber deviousness cockeyed originally
with Ganesha
Dharma means most pathetic a malinka
Monica Michelle module which get a baby
star now but you ought to be famous
don't you are amazing modification is
crawling back at you
[Music]
people enjoy mayhem especially when it
happens to other people this is
definitely a factor of schadenfreude
watching something go terribly wrong to
someone else
[Music]
Yuni u-haul you're about to start your
first semester at Duke and driving down
the road you see this side and another
side you may know tension and then this
time lights up and then disaster strikes
you're about to get your 15 minutes of
fame all thanks to this man hi i'm
uragan hen these infamous nice parts
right you're good
one could say that yes I am now I know
c11 put a guy around here you get it his
wife started eleven foot eight calm
which is what exactly eleven foot eight
website records all the truck crashes
that happen here at the 11 foot eight
bridge it's really all it is eight years
ago I set up camera outside my office
here and started recording the traffic
that goes under the railroad trestle
behind me within a few weeks I recorded
the truck crashing into the railroad
bridge since installing the camera
you're going to upload a video of a
hundred and thirteen crashes at the
bridge and amassed over ten million
views most bridges in the state have a
15 percent the 11 foot eight bridge
however because both 100 years ago its
lower height now experience these
crashes I've dedicated following I'll
fans are really intensely interested in
these crashes and they love to buy
souvenirs little piece of crash art
what's crusher the crash art are meant
mangled pieces of aluminum that
usually form the frame of the truck and
the impact crushes that aluminum and
kind of twisted in interesting shapes
people will buy the crash art they love
it
for summer room it's almost like owning
a piece of the Berlin wall whether the
town just raised the trestle or lower
the roof from the perspective of the
city and the state d-o-t the low
clearance is clearly marked and it's up
to the driver to decide their next move
structural changes that the intersection
would be extremely costly well if we
have these off videos right I get no
satisfaction out of being in you crash
it we found an actual solution to
prevent this tomorrow I'd be all over I
love it
[Music]
meet Jenny Lee my name is Jenny and I
lobbied for the dumpling takeout box
fortune cookies and chopsticks emojis
and this is a story of how Jenny is
getting us or new emoji like it it
smells to me like there should be a
dumpling MMG and I glommed or at it we
should add the takeout box fortune
cookie in chopsticks as of 2017 they're
coming to a keyboard interview Jenny was
on an emoji crusade I see in order to
pitch an emoji you have to infiltrate
this worldwide consortium maybe Unicode
you get very quickly to the Unicode
consortium which is a nonprofit
organization which basically oversees
emoji there are the people who control
the alphabet of your emoji keyboard it
has 11 full voting members they pay 18
thousand dollars a year to like have a
full vote unicode sets the standard and
parameters around emoji you see there
are a set of rules all emoji must abide
by there are no plans no deities and new
celebrities and when you hear about
quotes emoji those are not real accepted
emoji those are sort of like rogue emoji
that are really stickers so Jenny
started to attend meetings for a swift
75 bucks anyone can attend the meeting
as a non-voting member and you basically
like feel very welcome and so it feels a
lot like going to a new church back to
the dumpling what I did was you know
write a whole proposal about why the
dumpling deserves its own emoji
especially since is so Universal and
what's kind of cool is that like not
only is it a dumpling image it can be a
pierogi emoji or no empanada emoji got
that passed as a candidate emoji in
January of this year seems like a lot of
work for fun symbols now it's actually
much faster than I thought oh okay I
think it's really interesting to watch
the emoji evolve and that my friends is
how an emoji is born
[Music]
you got you you've got there
you've got you you've got man goodbye
you all of you who thought a o L was
voiced by a computer now let's set the
record straight I recorded those phrases
well done you've got mail files done
goodbye
my name is Elwood Edwards and I'm the
voice of you've got mail in 1989 my wife
was a customer service rep for the
company that was about to become America
Online she heard Steve Case talking to
some of the programmers about how fun it
would be to add a voice to the software
I've been an announcer throughout my
entire broadcasting career and she
volunteered me I scribbled those phrases
on a piece of paper and like I'd say on
the cassette deck I recorded the welcome
you've got mail files done goodbye
it started off as a test just to see if
it would catch on and lo and behold in
the mid-90s it had really caught on and
at one point they said my voice was
heard more than 35 million times a day
but the problem was I was typecast the
one thing I did do was a voice for The
Simpsons
you've got leprosy goodbye being
associated with AOL has been gratifying
even today you go on AOL comm I greet
you I greet myself
you